NEWS.
THERE IS SO MUCH OF IT, OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
STORE MACK TODAY AFTER WEEKS OF
BEING SMEARED BY DEMOCRATS,
CALLED EVIL, ACCUSED OF RATE AND
GANG RAPE AND COMPARED TO
BILL COSBY, AFTER WEEKS OF VILE
DEATH THREATS AGAINST HIS FAMILY
AND WEEKS OF BEING DEMONIZED ALL
OVER TELEVISION AND MOST MAJOR
NEWSPAPERS, TODAY BRETT
KAVANAUGH FINALLY HAD A CHANCE
UNDER OATH TO CLEAR HIS GOOD
NAME.
DRAMATIC TESTIMONY TODAY,
POWERFUL TESTIMONY.
WATCH THIS.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: THIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS HAS BECOME
A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
SENATE AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS, BUT YOU
HAVE REPLACED ADVICE AND CONSENT
WITH SEARCH AND DESTROY.
SINCE MY NOMINATION IN JULY,
THERE HAS BEEN A FRENZY ON THE
LEFT TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING,
ANYTHING, TO BLOCK MY
CONFIRMATION.
SHORTLY AFTER I WAS NOMINATED,
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATE LEADER
SAID HE WOULD QUOTE OPPOSE ME
WITH EVERYTHING HE'S GOT.
A DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ON THIS
COMMITTEE PUBLICLY REFERRED TO
ME AS EVIL, GIVEN COMMENTS LIKE
THOSE.
IS IT ANY SURPRISE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WILLING TO DO ANYTHING
TO MAKE ANY PHYSICAL THREAT
AGAINST MY FAMILY?
TO SEND ANY VIOLENT EMAIL TO MY
WIFE?
TO MAKE ANY KIND OF ALLEGATION
AGAINST ME AND AGAINST MY
FRIENDS, TO BLOW ME UP AND TAKE
ME DOWN?
YOU SEWED THE WIND.
FOR DECADES TO COME I FEAR THAT
THE WHOLE COUNTRY WILL REAP THE
WHIRLWIND.
>> JUDGE KAVANAUGH ALSO HAD THIS
TO SAY ABOUT THE PROCESS, AND
HIS FAMILY AND WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO ENDURE AGAIN WITH
ZERO CORROBORATION, NO
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND NO
DUE PROCESS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE BEHAVIOR OF SEVERAL OF
THE DEMOCRATS IN THIS HEARING A
FEW WEEKS AGO WAS AN
EMBARRASSMENT BUT AT LEAST IT
WAS A GOOD OLD-FASHIONED ATTEMPT
AT BARKING.
THOSE EFFORTS DIDN'T WORK.
I DID AT LEAST OKAY ENOUGH AT
THOSE HEARINGS AND IT LOOKS LIKE
I MIGHT GET CONFIRMED, A NEW
TACTIC WAS NEEDED.
SOME OF YOU ARE LYING AND RATE
COMIC WEIGHT AND HAD IT READY.
THIS FIRST ALLEGATION WAS HELD
IN SECRET FOR WEEKS BY A
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND BY STAFF.
IT WOULD BE NEEDED ONLY IF YOU
COULDN'T TAKE ME OUT ON THE
MERITS.
WHEN IT WAS NEEDED, THIS
ALLEGATION WAS UNLEASHED AND
PUBLICLY DEPLOYED OVER
DR. FORD'S WISHES.
THIS WHOLE TWO WEEK EFFORT HAS
BEEN A CALCULATED AND
ORCHESTRATED POLITICAL HIT.
FUELED WITH A PARENT PENT UP
ANGER ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE 2016 ELECTION, FEAR THAT HAS
BEEN UNFAIRLY STOKED ABOUT MY
JUDICIAL RECORD, REVENGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CLINTONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN IN MONEY
FROM OUTSIDE LEFT-WING
OPPOSITION GROUPS.
THIS IS A CIRCUS.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL EXTEND
LONG PAST MY NOMINATION.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE WITH US
FOR DECADES.
>> Sean: AFTER THOSE POWERFUL
REMARKS, JUDGE KAVANAUGH
ADDRESSED HIS ACCUSER, PROFESSOR
CHRISTINE FORD.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS EMOTIONAL
MOMENT FROM EARLIER TODAY.
I HAVE NEVER DONE THIS TO HER OR
ANYONE.
THAT'S NOT WHO I AM, IT'S NOT
WHO I WAS.
I AM INNOCENT OF THIS CHARGE.
I INTEND NO ILL WILL TO DR. FORD
AND HER FAMILY.
THE OTHER NIGHT ASHLEY AND MY
DAUGHTER LIZA SAID THEIR PRAYERS
AND, LITTLE LIES ALL OF TEN
YEARS OLD...
SAID TO ASHLEY, WE SHOULD PRAY
FOR THE WOMAN.
THAT'S A LOT OF WISDOM FROM A
10-YEAR-OLD.
>> >> Sean: WE ARE THAT ON MY
RADIO SHOW WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE
AROUND ME.
GUYS AND GIRLS, THEY ALL WERE
CRYING.
POWERFUL MOMENT AND SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
BUT LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO
REVIEW THE CHARGES FROM
PROFESSOR FORD, WHERE
ALLEGATIONS WERE MADE IN JULY TO
A DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
SHE CLAIMS THAT THOSE CLAIMS
COME BACK AFTER NEARLY FOUR
DECADES AND I'VE BEEN SAYING,
SHE DESERVED TO BE HEARD FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
THOSE ALLEGATIONS ARE SERIOUS
AND HAVE BEEN TAKEN SERIOUSLY BY
THE PRESIDENT, THE SENATE AND BY
EVERYBODY.
SHE DOESN'T REMEMBER A DATE, DAY
OF THE WEEK LOCATION, OR HOW SHE
GOT TO OR FROM THE PARTY WHERE
THE ALLEGED CRIME TOOK PLACE.
ALL OF THE WITNESSES THAT
PROFESSOR FORD CORROBORATED WITH
HER CLAIMS, THEY ALL DENIED THAT
SHE WAS ALLEGING.
ALL FOUR WITH SWORN STATEMENTS
UNDER PENALTY OF FELONY.
ALL WITNESSES HAVE GIVEN SWORN
STATEMENTS UNDER THE PENALTY OF
FELON, COULD FELONY MEANING YOU
COULD GO TO JAIL, TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT THIS HAS
BEEN INVESTIGATED AND THE PEOPLE
THERE HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN.
THAT INCLUDES PROFESSOR FORD'S
FRIEND, HER NAME, LELAND KEISER.
HER ATTORNEY RELEASED A
STATEMENT READING "SIMPLY PUT,
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUH
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUA
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUD
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUH
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUS
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUN
MS. KEISER DOES KNOW
MR. CAVANAUGH           KAVANAUO
RECOLLECTION OF BEING AT A PARTY
WHERE HE WAS PRESENT WITH OR
WITHOUT DR. FORD."
TODAY THE SENATE'S INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR ASKED HER ABOUT THIS
IRREFUTABLE FACT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THEY SAY
THEY HAVE NO MEMORY OR KNOWLEDGE
OF SUCH A PARTY?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
MOTIVES TO ASCRIBE TO LELAND?
>> I COULD TAKE THOSE ONE AT A
TIME.
LELAND HAS SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND I'M HAPPY THAT
SHE'S FOCUSING ON HERSELF AND
GETTING THESE HEALTH TREATMENTS
THAT SHE NEEDS.
SHE LET ME KNOW THAT SHE NEEDED
HER LAWYER TO TAKE CARE OF THIS
FOR HER, AND SHE TEXTED ME RIGHT
AFTERWARD WITH AN APOLOGY, AND
GOOD WISHES AND ET CETERA.
SO I'M GLAD SHE'S TAKING CARE OF
HERSELF.
>> THAT IS TESTIMONY FROM
PROFESSOR FORD WHICH ACTUALLY
RAISE MORE QUESTIONS THAN IT
ANSWERED, INCLUDING THIS MOMENT
ABOUT FORD'S RECENT POLYGRAPH
TEST.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS.
>> WHY WAS THAT LOCATION CHOSEN
FOR THE POLYGRAPH?
>> I HAD LEFT MY GRANDMOTHER'S
FUNERAL AT FORT LINCOLN CEMETERY
THAT DAY AND I WAS ON A TIGHT
SCHEDULE TO GET A PLANE TO
MANCHESTER, NEW HAMPSHIRE, SO HE
WAS WILLING TO COME TO ME WHICH
IS APPRECIATED.
>> SO HE ADMINISTERED A
POLYGRAPH ON THE DAY THAT YOU
ATTENDED YOUR GRANDMOTHER'S
FUNERAL?
>> CORRECT.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE NEXT DAY,
I SPENT THE NIGHT IN THE HOTEL.
NOT SURE OF THE EXACT DAY.
>> DID YOU PAY FOR THE POLYGRAPH
YOURSELF?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO DID PAY FOR
THE POLYGRAPH?
>> NOT YET, NO.
>> I BELIEVE YOU SAID IT HADN'T
BEEN PAID FOR YET, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> LET ME PUT AN END TO THIS
MISERY.
HER LAWYERS HAVE PAID FOR HER
POLYGRAPH.
>> AS IS ROUTINE.
>> AS HIS ROUTINE.
IS IT YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING TO ASSIST
YOU WITH SOME OF THESE FEES
INCLUDING THE COST FOR YOUR
POLYGRAPH?
>> I'M AWARE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN SEVERAL GO FIND ME SITES
THAT I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MANAGE THOSE,
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER HAD ONE.
>> TO RECAP, PROFESSOR FORD
DOESN'T REMEMBER WHEN THE
INCIDENT HAPPENED AND SHE IS
GIVEN INCONSISTENT ANSWERS ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT DETAIL.
SHE DOESN'T REMEMBER EXACTLY WHO
ATTENDED THE PARTY IN QUESTION.
SHE HAS GIVEN INCONSISTENT
ANSWERS ABOUT THIS DETAIL AND
SHE DOESN'T REMEMBER HOW SHE GOT
TO THE ALLEGED PARTY.
BACK FROM THE PARTY AND NOT ONE
PERSON CORROBORATES HER STORY.
WE ALSO LEARNED TODAY SHE
DOESN'T REMEMBER IF SHE HANDED
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THERAPY
NOTES JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
JUST MINUTES AGO,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
EDITORIAL BOARD FULLY ENDORSED
THE CONFIRMATION OF JUDGE BRETT
KAVANAUGH AND ALSO MOMENTS AGO
WE LEARNED THAT SENATOR MITCH
McCONNELL ANNOUNCED THE SENATE
JUDICIAL COMMITTEE THEY ARE
MOVING FORWARD HE SAID.
AND MOMENTS AGO, SENATOR BOB
CORKER OF TENNESSEE ANNOUNCED ON
TWITTER THAT HE WILL VOTE YES ON
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
TWO PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE, IT
SHOULDN'T BE ABOUT DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN OR LIBERAL
CONSERVATIVE AT ALL.
THEY WANTED TO RUIN JUDGE BRETT
KAVANAUGH, AND UNSUBSTANTIATED
AND UNCORROBORATED CLAIMS FROM
NEARLY FOUR DECADES AGO.
FROM THE LEFT AT THIS POINT,
IT'S NOT ABOUT
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT KEITH ELLISON.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD MORE ARE
STATEMENTS ABOUT BILL CLINTON.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN ABOUT
PROTECTING VICTIMS OR FINDING
THE TRUTH.
FOR THEM, DAY ONE WITH
CHUCK SCHUMER LEAVING THE WAY,
IT'S A SAD DAY FOR THE COUNTRY
AND WHAT WE HAD TO WITNESS
TODAY.
THE WORST PART OF THIS IS,
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN KNEW
ABOUT THESE CLAIMS SINCE JULY.
SHE KNEW ABOUT THESE CHARGES
WHEN SHE ACTUALLY MET WITH
KAVANAUGH IN PRIVATE.
SHE KNEW ABOUT THESE CLAIMS WHEN
SHE QUESTIONED HIM DURING HIS
PUBLIC HEARING SEVERAL WEEKS
AGO.
WHEN SHE MET PRIVATELY WITH
BRETT KAVANAUGH, SHE HAD ALREADY
BEEN RECOMMENDING ATTORNEYS TO
PROFESSOR FORD.
ONLY AFTER BRETT KAVANAUGH'S
NOMINATION LOOKED IMMINENT DID
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND DEMOCRATS
ANNOUNCE FORD'S ALLEGATIONS.
THIS HAS BEEN A DISGRACEFUL
DISPLAY OF POLITICS AT ITS WORS
WORST.
HIS REELECTION MORE IMPORTANT
THEN ANOTHER PERSON'S LIFE HERE?
DID ANYONE HEAR THE PAIN IN
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S VOICE TODAY?
AND I WOULD ARGUE TOO, PROFESSOR
FORD TO COME UP AS SUSAN COLLINS
HAS SAID IT, NOBODY HAS BEEN
SERVED WELL HERE.
THE STORY GOT LEAKED, HER NAME
GOT LEAKED AND WITHOUT ANY
CORROBORATION OR EVIDENCE, THEN
YOU HAVE POLITICIANS SMEARING
CAVANAUGH AGAIN AND AGAIN ON
NATIONAL TV.
AND THIS IS JUST A SMALL
SAMPLING.
>> THE SENATE SHOULDN'T SIMPLY
RELY ON HEARING TWO CONFLICTING
ACCOUNTS, AND WE ARE OKAY WITH
NOT KNOWING AND WE MIGHT BE
PUTTING SOMEONE WHO COMMITTED
ATTEMPTED RAPE ON THE SOUTHERN
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> I BELIEVE HER.
LISTEN, FIRST OF ALL, ANYONE WHO
COMES FORWARD AT THIS POINT TO
BE PREPARED TO TESTIFY IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AGAINST
SOMEONE WHO IS BEING NOMINATED
TO ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
POSITIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT, THAT TAKES AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF COURAGE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE
DR. FORD WHO BRAVELY COME
FORWARD NEED TO BE HEARD, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
>> I WANT TO SAY THAT TO THE MEN
OF THIS COUNTRY, JUST SHUT UP
AND STEP UP AND DO THE RIGHT
THING.
>> LET ME SAY AT THE OUTSET, I
BELIEVE DR. FORD, I BELIEVE THE
SURVIVOR HERE, THERE IS EVERY
REASON TO BELIEVE HER.
SHE'S COME FORWARD BRAVELY.
>> >> I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD
BE BULLIED INTO THIS SCENARIO,
OR IS HE SAID, SHE SAID.
IT'S A SHAME HEARING.
>> I BELIEVE PROFESSOR FORD.
I THINK SHE'S CREDIBLE AND I
THINK WHEN THE INVESTIGATION IS
FINISHED, AND WHEN SHE TESTIFIE
TESTIFIES, AND WHEN JUDGE
KAVANAUGH TESTIFIES, I THINK THE
MAJORITY OF SENATORS WILL FIND
HER CREDIBLE.
>> Sean: THE SMEARS CONTINUED
DURING THE HEARING AND TODAY
DEMOCRATS RAMPING UP THEIR
FAVORITE NEW TALKING POINT.
WE MUST HAVE AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THIS IS OF COURSE ALL A
POLITICAL STALL TACTIC.
THEY WANT DELAY, DELAY, DELAY.
THE HOPE WE GET TO THE MIDTERMS,
THEY HOPE THEY WIN AND THEY HOPE
THEY STOP DONALD TRUMP FROM
FULFILLING A CAMPAIGN PROMISE
AND CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION.
WATCH THE ECHO CHAMBER AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS, I WILL
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS PHONY, AND
THEY KNOW IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: THE
BEHAVIOR OF SEVERAL DEMOCRATIC
EMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE A FEW
WEEKS AGO AT MY HEARING WAS AN
EMBARRASSMENT, BUT AT LEAST IT
WAS JUST AN OLD-FASHIONED
ATTEMPTS AT BORKING.
WHEN I DID OKAY AT THE HEARINGS
ENOUGH TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE I
MIGHT GET CONFIRMED, NEW TACTICS
WERE NEEDED.
SOME OF YOU WERE LYING IN WAIT,
AND HAD IT READY.
THIS FIRST ALLEGATION WAS HELD
IN SECRET FOR WEEKS BY A
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND BY STAFF.
IT WOULD BE NEEDED ONLY IF YOU
COULDN'T TAKE ME OUT ON THE
MERITS.
WHEN IT WAS NEEDED, THIS
ALLEGATION WAS UNLEASHED AND
PUBLICLY DEPLOYED OVER
DR. FORD'S WISHES.
THIS WHOLE TWO-WEEK EFFORT HAS
BEEN A CALCULATED AND
ORCHESTRATED POLITICAL HIT.
FUELED WITH A PARENT PENT UP
ANGER ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE 2016 ELECTION, I FEAR THAT
HAS BEEN UNFAIRLY STOKED ABOUT
MY JUDICIAL RECORD, REVENGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CLINTONS, AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN MONEY
FROM OUTSIDE LEFT-WING
OPPOSITION GROUPS.
THIS IS A CIRCUS.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL EXTEND
LONG PAST MY NOMINATION.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE WITH US
FOR DECADES.
>> Sean: AN FBI INVESTIGATION
DOES NOT MAKE CONCLUSIONS, THEY
ALL KNEW THIS.
THEY INTERVIEWED EVERYBODY THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN INTERVIEWED AND
A REPORT WOULD THEN BE ISSUED.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT THE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE ACTUALLY
USELESS, AS WORDS, AND THEY ALL
AGREED BACK THEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE NEXT PERSON THAT REFERS
TO AN FBI REPORT AS BEING WORTH
ANYTHING OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND ANYTHING.
FBI EXPLICITLY DOES NOT IN THIS
OR ANY OTHER CASE REACH A
CONCLUSION.
PERIOD.
SO JUDGE, THERE'S NO REASON WHY
YOU SHOULD KNOW THIS.
THE REASON WHY WE CAN'T RELY ON
THE FBI REPORT, HE WOULD LIKE IT
IF WE DID BECAUSE IT IS
INCONCLUSIVE.
THEY SAY HE SAID, SHE SAID AND
THEY SAID, PERIOD.
SO WHEN PEOPLE WAIVE AN FBI
REPORT BEFORE YOU, UNDERSTAND,
THEY DO NOT.
THEY DO NOT REACH CONCLUSIONS.
THEY DO NOT MAKE, AS MY FRIEND
POINTS OUT MORE ADEQUATELY, THEY
DO NOT MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
>> Sean: IT REMEMBER ALL
WITNESSES IN THIS CASE GAVE
SWORN STATEMENTS UNDER THE
THREAT OF FELONY.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TURNED THIS
IMPORTANT PROCESS INTO A
POLITICAL SHAM.
THEY HAVE TURNED ADVICE AND
CONSENT INTO DESTROY AND MALIGN.
THEY CAN'T CARE WHOSE LIFE IS
DESTROYED IN THIS PROCESS,
OBVIOUSLY THEY DON'T.
DID THEY NOT SEE WHAT WENT ON
TODAY, TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH?
THE IMPACT ON HIM AND HIS
FAMILY?
THE WOMEN MAKING THESE
ALLEGATIONS AS THEY WITHHELD
THEM FOR ALL THESE WEEKS?
THEY JUST WANT CAVANAUGH STOPPED
AT ALL COSTS.
NO ONE SEEMS TO PUT THIS IN
BETTER PERSPECTIVE THAN
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
AND PLEASE TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HOPE YOU WIN IN 2020, AND
YOU SAID THAT, NOT ME.
YOU HAVE NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR.
WHEN YOU SEE JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR
OR AND KAGAN, I VOTED FOR THEM
BUT I WOULD NEVER DO TO THEM
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO THIS GUY.
THIS IS THE MOST UNETHICAL SHAM
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN POLITICS.
I CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY HAVE GONE THROUGH.
YOU ALL WANT POWER, I HOPE YOU
NEVER GET IT.
I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN
SEE THROUGH THE SHAM, THAT YOU
KNEW ABOUT IT AND YOU HELD IT.
YOU HAD NO INTENTION OF
PROTECTING DR. FORD.
NONE.
SHE'S AS MUCH OF A VICTIM AS YOU
ARE.
GOD, I HATE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THESE HAVE BEEN MY FRIENDS, BUT
LET ME TELL YOU, WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS, YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A
FAIR PROCESS?
YOU CAME TO THE WRONG TOWN AT
THE WRONG TIME, MY FRIEND.
TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, IF
YOU VOTE NO, YOU ARE
LEGITIMIZING THE MOST DESPICABLE
THING I HAVE SEEN IN MY TIME IN
POLITICS.
>> Sean: SENATOR GRAHAM WILL
JOIN US IN STUDIO IN JUST A
MOMENT, AND AFTER THOSE
PASSIONATE REMARKS,
SENATOR ORRIN HATCH CALLED THESE
PROCEEDINGS WORSE THAN ANY OTHER
CONFIRMATION PROCEEDINGS IN
HISTORY, INCLUDING THOSE OF
JUDGE BORK AND JUDGE THOMAS.
LET'S WATCH THIS.
>> OF THE CIRCUS ATMOSPHERE THAT
HAS BEEN CREATED SINCE MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES FIRST
LEAKED DR. FORD'S ALLEGATIONS TO
THE MEDIA TWO WEEKS AGO, AFTER
SITTING ON THEM FOR SIX WEEKS, I
MIGHT ADD IT, HAS BROUGHT US THE
WORST IN OUR POLITICS.
IT CERTAINLY HAS BROUGHT US NO
CLOSER TO THE TRUTH, ANONYMOUS
LETTERS WITH NO NAME AND NO
RETURN ADDRESS ARE NOT BEING
TREATED AS NATIONAL NEWS.
LAWYERS WITH FACIALLY
IMPLAUSIBLE CLAIMS ARE DRIVING
THE NEW CYCLE.
I HATE TO SAY THIS, BUT THIS IS
WORSE THAN ROBERT BORK AND I
DIDN'T THINK IT COULD GET WORSE
THAN THAT.
THIS IS WORSE THAN CLARENCE
THOMAS AND I DIDN'T THINK IT
COULD GET WORSE THAN THAT.
THIS IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE, THE
WAY YOU ARE BEING TREATED.
>> Sean: THIS IS SADLY THE
DEMOCRATIC PLAYBOOK.
I WARN PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE TWO
OR FOUR YEARS ON A RADIO SHOW
AND RIGHT HERE ON THE SHOW,
REPUBLICANS, BE PREPARED TO BE
DEMONIZED, RACIST, SEXIST,
MISOGYNIST, ISLAMOPHOBIC, XENA
PHOBIC, YOU WANT DIRTY AIR AND
WATER AND YOU WANT TO KILL
CHILDREN AND THEIR SON PAUL RYAN
LOOK A LIKE THROWING YOUR
GRANDMOTHER OVER THE CLIFF
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS WANT GRANNY
TO DIE.
IT'S THE SAME NOW WITH
SUPREME COURT NOMINEES, SAME
PREDICTABLE BEHAVIOR.
WE HAVE NOW COME TO EXPECT THIS.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE, THIS COUNTRY
DESERVES BETTER.
THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY
DESERVE BETTER.
THESE PEOPLE IN D.C., AND THIS
SWAMP, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
SERVE US, YOU, WE COME AT THE
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT A REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, LIBERAL OR
CONSERVATIVE HERE, THIS IS PURE
HUMAN DECENCY THAT WAS IN PLAY
TODAY.
THEY DESTROYED THIS MAN AND HIS
FAMILY.
THEY BLUDGEONED HIM, ALL FOR THE
SAKE OF POWER.
THERE WAS ZERO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE HERE OR DUE PROCESS.
NOW THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EVERY
2-4 YEARS, EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
NOMINATION TO THE SUPREME COURT,
WE KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
THE PARTY OF SLANDER, BESMIRCH
MEANT, SMEARS, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, THE PARTY OF NO
DUE PROCESS, NO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
THE PARTY THAT RUSHES TO
JUDGMENT.
LOOK AT ALL THE HIGH PROFILE
CASES RUSHED TO JUDGMENT.
THE DUKE LACROSSE CLICK CASE,
CAMBRIDGE POLICE, BALTIMORE,
MARYLAND, RICHARD JEWELL, TRAVE
ON MARTIN.
IS THIS THE PARTY THAT IS GOING
TO DECIDE THE FATE OF THIS
COUNTRY?
BECAUSE IN 40 DAYS, THAT SAME
PARTY WANTS YOU TO GO OUT AND
VOTE FOR THEM.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
USING THESE REPUBLICAN SENATORS?
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
DECIDE THE FATE OF THE KAVANAUGH
NOMINATION.
RIGHT THERE.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WILL
DECIDE IF WE STILL HAVE DUE
PROCESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF THESE PRINCIPLES EXIST IN
THIS COUNTRY, IF WE STILL HAVE
LAWS PREDICATED ON THE
CONSTITUTION, LET THEM KNOW HOW
TO VOTE.
CALL THEM.
TELL THEM WHAT IS AT STAKE.
LET THEM KNOW WHAT YOU FELT
TODAY WATCHING THESE HEARINGS,
AND IF YOU ARE IN ONE OF THE
STATES WHERE DONALD TRUMP ONE,
WEST VIRGINIA, JOE MANCHIN,
NORTH DAKOTA HEIDI HEITKAMP,
INDIANA JOE DONNELLY, YOU'RE A
SENATORS UP FOR REELECTION.
THEY DON'T CONFIRM JUDGE
KAVANAUGH AND THEY GO ALONG WITH
THE SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
IF THEY GO AHEAD AND DO THAT,
ARE YOU GOING TO VOTE FOR THEM?
THERE IS A LOT IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS, WEEKS AND MONTHS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO DECIDE AND WE HAVE
A LOT TO GET TO IN THE COURSE OF
THIS PROGRAM TONIGHT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT HERE TONIGHT, WHAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT, YOU GET TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR YOUR
DECISIONS.
NEVER HAS A SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION BEEN MORE IMPORTANT.
THIS COUNTRY IS AT A TIPPING
POINT.
INALIENABLE RIGHTS OF AMERICANS
WILL CONTINUE OR WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK.
OUR CONSTITUTION, ALL THESE CORE
PRINCIPLES HANG IN THE BALANCE
TONIGHT AND WE HAVE ONE PARTY
THAT IS THROWING ALL OF THIS TO
THE WIND AND ADOPTED SMEAR,
SLANDER, PERSONAL POLITICS AND
DESTRUCTION, AND UNLESS GOOD
SENATORS FIND A BACK BORN AND
STICK UP FOR THESE CORE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
DUE PROCESS, JUSTICE, LAW,